hi my name is Eric and I work on Android
I'm here to tell you about some cool
features of the Android 1.5 release one
of the main additions we've introduced
in this update is the virtual keyboard
it has a bunch of cool features you can
set it up so that as you type it gives
you tactile feedback by vibrating the
screen a pretty handy trick if you're
not used to typing on a touchscreen it
also gives suggestions and auto corrects
your spelling so that you can type
quickly and easily the virtual keyboard
works in any application Gmail the
browser SMS and even third-party apps
but what's also nice is that apps have
the ability to flip between landscape
and portrait mode so the virtual
keyboard is great but if you don't feel
like typing or if you're searching for a
long or hard to spell phrase you can
simply say your search using search by
voice another new set of features we've
added to Android includes video
recording playback and sharing recording
a video is really straightforward simply
point and shoot say hi Jim
[Music]
sharing videos with friends couldn't be
easier
simply click share and choose how to
share it you can email SMS or even
upload directly to YouTube Jim you and
your funny hat are about to get famous
and while the upload happens in the
background you can continue using the
phone as usual make a call text or even
record an upload a new video another
cool feature is the ability to customize
your phone with home screen widgets that
provide immediate access to valuable
information and applications the phone
comes preloaded with great widgets like
calendar a music player and google
search we're really excited to see what
new widgets developers come up with next
you can find these new widgets and of
course great applications in Android
Market for more information on
Android and the Android 1.5 release
please visit Android comm
you